[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and welcome to
the world of ps5
accessories so first of all if you've
gotten your hands on a ps5 congrats
seriously congrats it's not easy right
now if you haven't gotten one yet my
fingers are crossed for you hopefully
you get it soon but once you do get a
ps5 it's kind of like a smartphone you
set it up and you kind of want to make
it your own a little bit maybe customize
it so now that i've had the ps5 for
about three months now i've sorted
through some stuff not a whole ton out
there as far as customizations for it
but once you do actually buy some and
try it some of it is garbage i won't be
recommending it some of it is actually
pretty good so here are the best
accessories for customizing
your experience so number one is
obviously it's a gaming console finding
some good games to play and a lot of
this is preference but we've we've seen
the games library slowly growing as
expected with the new console generation
a lot of my recommendations are still
the same once you get it you gotta play
astros playroom just to really get to
know the controller and i think you
gotta get the spider-man game the miles
morales game just because in my opinion
it's the most visual immersive game on
the ps5 there's a reason it launched
with it it feels like it's built for the
ps5 has a pretty good storyline i like
it uh slack boy a big adventure came out
shortly after it's been getting some
pretty good reviews and i've personally
been playing a lot of nba 2k 21 but
let's be real it's pretty similar to
last year just with some improved
graphics and a slightly different my
character story but whatever you're into
i'll leave a list of games that have
gotten some good reviews for the ps5
right below that like button but that's
not really customization right you
install the games
you go through the ui just like
everybody else everyone's ps5 software
experience is more or less the same
thing but there are some things you can
do to change the rest of the experience
so first of all the look of the ps5 was
one of the most controversial things
about it at launch now three months
later it's kind of grown on me like i'm
used to seeing it next to my tv but
maybe you don't like it maybe you want
the actual console to look different so
that is where
base plates come in so you may have
heard by now that these uh these pieces
on the side of the ps5 that kind of make
it look like an alien spaceship are just
plastic and they literally pop off so if
you pull hard enough from the corners it
just pops right off from the plastic and
so if you buy a different color face
plate like this one which is dbrand's
matte black dark plate you can pop it on
the exact same way and now your ps5 is
different color so this is the most
fundamental way to get a very different
looking console than the way it came out
the box i think it's better than a skin
because it's actually way easier than
installing a huge skin and it's also
impressively high quality like it looks
and feels exactly like the same stock
sony face plates except for the fact
that all the tiny x's and o's from
sony's pattern are replaced with tiny
robots and skulls for dbrand's version
currently it is only matte black which
is the best color obviously but i am
kind of curious why there aren't more
alternate
shapes and also alternate colors like i
would i think it'd be cool if there was
a red and a blue version you could just
do whatever color you want for your ps5
i'm not just saying this because they're
a channel sponsor they didn't sponsor
this video but i happen to really like
these so
dark plates honestly the real downside
is it looks like they're about as hard
to get right now as the ps5 itself maybe
they'll arrive at the same time i don't
know onto some other stuff so the middle
plastic part like i mentioned in the
review is still this glossy plastic
collects fingerprints and dust and
eventually scratches there are also
skins for this dbrand will happily sell
you a skin for the middle part and you
can go for this contrasty look you could
go matte black everything you could go
reverse ice cream sandwich you can do
whatever you want with the colors here
but what about the controllers these are
some of my favorite controllers ever in
any console actually they probably are
at the top of my list and so is there
anything you can do to customize the
controllers turns out yes so we've all
seen the black and white by now this
black piece is actually also a face
plate kind of the same way as the ps5
there's a lot more connection points but
you can remove it now this one's a
little harder to pry off because of all
those extra connection points so you may
require some assistance in the form of a
thin pry tool but this one i got from
amazon actually came with this blue
pride tool so they thought ahead so i'm
going to link this one below just try
not to break the plastic piece that
you're taking off in case you ever want
to go back to it but then this
is the controller face plate and it
clips on the exact same way as the piece
you just took off so i just got the sky
blue color because it shipped the
fastest and it looks pretty good to me
but there's a ton of colors available at
that link so you can go dark blue you
can go red or orange or gold the world
is your oyster and it's cheap it's like
15 bucks for a new color plastic on your
controller you know it's not quite as
cheap but also
still i think 100 worth it is this
entirely painted
fully customized controller by colorware
so if you guys have watched the videos
for a while you've heard me talk about
colorware before they take apart
paint and put together all kinds of
devices and they do an incredible job
every time so what you're looking at
right now is a one of one mkbhd edition
ps5 controller they made but you can go
if you want fully matte black on your
controller the thing about a controller
though is it gets the most wear and tear
because you're holding it all the time
so matte black looks sick when it's
brand new but it might not be the way to
go with plastic maybe a little matte red
or blue or something like that either
way you do you you can go on the site
and go crazy with the customizer change
the body color the front color the
buttons make it as beautiful or as ugly
as you want it's up to you also compared
to the normal prices of some other stuff
this is actually a little more
reasonable it's 109 bucks
which the controller by itself is
already 69 so
not bad but then there is
storage so whenever you get a ps5
whether you get the digital version or
the disk drive version you have 825 gigs
of storage before the os install so
maybe you want some extra storage some
games are huge some games sort of
require you thinking about storage
management the thing about the ps5 is
the external storage is only actually
supported for ps4 games
so
kind of a bummer but at least if you
have a library of ps4 games you can move
it to external storage to give yourself
more room on the console for ps5 games
so it's not ideal but if you want to do
this there are two versions of extra
storage internal or external so the
external drive it's easy you just plug
in a fast compatible drive by usb and
boom you just added up to eight
terabytes of space to keep all the ps4
games you could possibly want a matter
of fact this is an 8 terabyte drive from
western digital ps5 sees it when you
plug it in you can format it it's no
problem the other option is an internal
m2 ssd shout out to austin evans who
just dropped his
ultimate ps5 video where he goes a
little crazy with it but you can see
inside the ps5 there is actually a slot
for internal extra storage and so same
deal only ps4 games and it will require
an upcoming firmware update on the ps5
to work so it's not going to work right
away but hey if you want to do it that
way that's one less cable on your tv
stand that's one less thing you have to
worry about on the outside of the ps5 a
little cleaner but i'll link austin's
video below if you want to watch the
destruction or modification of a ps5
to the extreme so that's the meat of it
then there are a bunch of uh
not quite as useful but still kind of
cool accessories depending on who you
are so like the ps5 controller dock that
sony made looks like a baby ps5 it's
cool and everything it's pretty cheap
it's like 30 bucks but it's not actually
that great like i found it pretty
finicky every time i wanted to try to
line up the pins and the magnets to
charge the controllers so i was looking
into alternate docks and you can get
other controller docks turns out they're
all pretty finicky trying to line up the
pins to charge this one i found here has
a few more lights on it and it's a bit
more stable
but yeah it's it's barely better it's
barely better than the stock one but
it's still cheap so i guess that's no
problem
then there's the docks
yeah ps5 docks so they're everywhere and
they really just hold up the ps5
vertically if you're into that
and some will give you extra usb ports
so this one i'm going to link below here
it gives you some stuff if you want to
plug in some lower powered stuff like
controllers through the hub and they
even put some fans in the bottom to push
air up through the ps5 now i really
doubt that that's making any difference
in performance at all
but it's there so it's really just
giving you an all-in-one hub for
charging your controllers keeping the
ps5 upright that's what a dock is good
for don't expect like a bump in your
frame rate or anything best thing you
can actually do for a ps5 is just keep
it in a sort of well ventilated area a
lot of consoles are a little tight for
it you want airflow generally to be able
to flow freely around it that's the best
thing you can do for performance and
every once in a while you can take these
plates off and clean it out for dust
we've heard ps4s get loud in the past
really loud including mine
and that's just because the fans are
spinning extra hard to get the same
amount of air through it so pro tip
clean it every once in a while so you
can do all that and for a cherry on top
you could grab yourself a pair of
dedicated like really nice gaming
headphones this is part of steelseries
arctics and they're they're really high
quality they sound phenomenal you can
get a wireless version or a version that
plugs straight into the ps5 controller
so that's nice
and then you're set that's that is the
extent of good ps5 accessories that you
should get that can actually
meaningfully change your experience so
there you have it good luck getting your
ps5 good luck getting your hands on the
accessories all the helpful links will
be below but that's been it thanks for
watching
i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]